the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our subject matter today concerns
that phase of calculus known as the
indefinite integral or the
antiderivative in terms of the concepts
that we've talked about so far in our
course and keeping in mind that one
concept with many applications is
educationally more meaningful than many
concepts each with one application I
prefer to call today's lesson the
inverse derivative or inverse
differentiation and again bring into
play a very well-known feature of our
course namely our discussion of inverse
functions now you see the only problem
that comes up in this context is a
rather simple one and that is that all
the time that we've been taking a
derivative we may not have realized that
we were using the idea of a function in
a rather different way namely notice
that by taking a derivative we had a
rule which told us how given a
particular function to assign to it a
new function called its derivative in
other words what we could have done is
to have visualized a different function
machine which I will call the D machine
hopefully the D will suggest
differentiation with the domain of my D
machine in other words the input of my D
machine will be differentiable functions
and the output you see the image of my D
machine will be the derivative of that
particular function so in other words
then if we want to use our typical
notation what we're saying is that the D
machine does what given a differentiable
function as its input the output will be
the derivative F prime now again we're
used to talking about the derivative
with respect to a given variable unless
otherwise specified the variable is X
and so perhaps with that in mind maybe
it would be more suggestive if I were to
do some
thing like this to indicate you see that
the input is f of X and the output is f
prime of X now you may recall also that
long before we started dealing with
functions of real variables we discussed
functions in general in terms of circle
diagrams and the like in this respect
notice that we can think of our D
machine as operating on a particular
domain the domain being what the set of
all differentiable functions and the
range or the image will also be what all
functions which are derivatives of
differentiable functions now what kind
of a function is d don't lose track of
the fact that things like one two
oneness and on Tunis are concepts that
transcend dealing with numbers they deal
they apply whenever we're dealing with
any kind of a function the idea is
something like this if x squared were to
go into the D machine the output would
be 2x see x squared is mapped into 2x x
cubed is mapped into 3x squared see the
derivative of x cubed with respect to X
is 3x squared x squared plus 7 also
mapped into 2x in other words without
going any further notice that whatever D
is d is not one-to-one you see two
different functions can have the same
derivative in fact many different
functions can have the same derivative
for example once we know that the
derivative of x squared is 2x we
certainly know that the derivative of x
squared plus any constant is also 2x in
other words then we cannot make an
inverse function machine as things stand
here and why is that to have an inverse
function what you must be able to do is
to reverse arrowheads and still have a
function notice that in a way D inverse
would be a little bit of a tricky thing
to talk about here
pretend that we quit anyway in other
words what would go wrong if we try to
build a D inverse machine well in terms
of the example that we're talking about
if the input to the D inverse machine
happened to be 2x then there would be
infinitely many different outputs that
were sure of namely what every function
of the form x squared plus C where C is
a constant and what I mean we can be
sure of that many you see all I know
going back to this diagram here is that
every function of the form x squared
plus C will map into 2x under the
derivative function the other question
that comes up is how do you know that
you can find a function whose derivative
is 2x that comes from a function which
doesn't have the form x squared plus C
how do you know there isn't some other
function f of X which has the property
that f of X maps into to X in other
words the derivative of f of X is 2x
even though f of X does not have the
form x squared plus C and you know this
is exactly where the mean value theorem
comes in to help us over here you see
what we're saying here is suppose that d
of f of X is 2x all we know is that when
you run f of X through the D machine
it's you wind up with 2x towards what
does that mean f prime of X is 2x well
we know that the root of x squared is
also 2x therefore whatever f of X is by
the corollary to the mean value theorem
that we've studied before since f of X
and x squared have identical derivatives
namely they're both 2x it means that
they must differ by a constant in other
words f of X minus x squared is a
constant but to say that f of X minus x
squared is a constant is the same as
saying that f of X belongs to the family
x squared plus C in other words f of X
equals x squared plus a constant but the
mean value theorem tells us is not only
does every function of the form x
squared plus C have its derivative with
the 2x but every function whose
derivative is 2x has the form
x-squared + Z to generalize this to
generalize this consider the following
suppose were given f of X ok and we now
say look at every time you differentiate
a function if you add on a constant you
don't change anything meaning what the
root of a constant is zero you notice
what we're saying is if the derivative
of f of X is f prime of X any function
of the form f of X plus C will have the
same derivative and not only that the
only function whose derivative is f
prime of X must be one of these that's
what this a sub F stands for you see
what I'm really saying here is that
certainly when you change the constant
you change the function the point is
with respect to the thing called the
derivative you cannot tell the
difference between two functions just by
looking at their derivatives if they
differ by a constant in other words with
respect to differentiation two functions
which differ by a constant are
equivalent and that's why I invented
this notation a of F all I'm saying is
that if we visualize now that the input
of the D machine is not individual
functions but whole classes of functions
in other words such as they differ only
by a constant then you see there is a
one-to-one correspondence between the
input and the output now that's a subtle
point it's a point which I'm sure most
of you will grasp but more importantly
the important thing is simply that once
we've seen one function with a given
derivative in a manner of speaking we've
seen them all in other words we only
have enough leeway as to fool around
with an arbitrary constant
so let's generalize again what do we
mean by D inverse of f of X we mean what
the set of all functions G of X whose
derivative with respect to X is the
given f of X see that's exactly what the
inverse function means and by the way
notice that this tells me my set
implicitly let me put that in
parenthesis over here namely suppose
somebody says does G of X belong to this
particular set called D inverse all I
have to do is differentiate the given G
and see if I get F if I do G belongs to
the set if I don't it doesn't belong to
the set but as we've so often stressed
about inverse functions notice that the
test to see whether something belongs to
D inverse it's sufficient to know how to
differentiate by the way to summarize
what we did before the explicit to list
this thing explicitly notice that what
we're saying is to find the set of all
functions whose derivative is little f
of X all we have to do is what find one
function capital F whose derivative is
little F and then I've set explicitly is
what the set of all functions of the
form capital f of X plus C where C is an
arbitrary constant now I'm sure this
concept is not difficult for you to
grasp for those of you who have been
through calculus before as the as our
course is intended to be for this type
of person to you see you may not be
familiar with the notation the D inverse
notation which I want to stress here but
the concept I hope is clear in its own
right now of course you see the problem
that comes up is that it's much easier
to differentiate a function than it is
to be given a function and then have to
try to find what you have to
differentiate to get it without meaning
it as facetiously as it may sound I use
this in on many occasions I prefer to
say it is much easier you see to
scramble an egg than to unscramble
I'm told what to differentiate that's
easy enough to do given the derivative
that may not be so easy let's look in
terms of an example and but this is
again a very nice teachers trick you
start with the problem to get the right
answer you start with the answer and
then work to the problem I'll start with
the function H of x equals x times the
square root of x squared plus 1 or
written more conveniently in exponential
notation x times x squared plus 1 to the
1/2
let me differentiate that remember this
is a product the relevant product is
what it's the first factor which is x
times the derivative of the second that
means what I bring the 1/2 down to a
power one less times the derivative of
what's inside with respect to X see the
same old chain rule again that's 2x then
what plus the second factor x squared
plus 1 to the 1/2 times the derivative
of the first with respect to X which is
1 at any in any rate simplifying
bringing the minus 1/2 power into the
denominator then putting everything over
a common denominator I wind up with the
fact that H prime of X is 2x squared
plus 1 over the square root of x squared
plus 1 I hope I haven't made a careless
error here but again one of the beauties
of a new mathematics is that it's the
method that's important ok now at any
rate what do I know starting with H of X
equaling x times the square root of x
squared plus 1 I now know that its
derivative is 2x squared plus 1 over the
square root of x squared plus 1 let's
write that in terms of Rd inverse
notation namely what we're saying is
that x times the square root of x
squared plus 1 has the property that its
derivative is 2x squared plus 1 over the
square root of x squared plus 1
consequently every function which has
the property that its derivative is 2x
squared plus 1 over the square root of x
squared plus 1 must come from this
family you see see everything of this
form will have its derivative equal to
and secondly any other function cannot
have its derivative equal to this by our
corollary to the mean value theorem now
I see what I'm saying is and here's the
beauty of what we mean by inverse
operations and the like it's conceivable
that you might not have been
sophisticated enough at this stage in
the game to have been able to deduce
this had we been given this notice that
my cue trick was I started with this
found out what the derivative was and
then just inverted the emphasis the
change in emphasis again however notice
the following suppose you weren't able
to find this and somebody said to you I
wonder if X times the square root of x
squared plus 1 is a function whose
derivative is equal to this and all I'm
saying without going through the work
again because I've already done that is
to simply observe that even if you did
not know this explicit representation by
definition D inverse of 2x squared plus
1 over the square root of x squared plus
1 is simply what the set of all
functions G of X such that G prime of X
is equal to 2x squared plus 1 over the
square root of x squared plus 1 in other
words given any function at all I could
differentiate it if the derivative came
out to be this then I have a solution it
belongs to the solution set otherwise it
doesn't but again notice that to solve
any D inverse problem it's sufficient to
understand a corresponding derivative
property in fact maybe now is a good
time to show how we get certain recipes
for D inverse type things let me just
write down a typical one you see D
inverse of X to the N is X to the n plus
1 over n plus 1 plus a constant
and of course observe that as soon as
you see something like this you have to
beware of N equals negative 1
otherwise we have a 0 denominator now a
person says this doesn't look familiar
to me again keep in mind what D inverse
means essentially to say this is just a
switch in emphasis from saying what that
you run the family of functions X to the
n plus 1 over n plus 1 plus a constant
through your D machine you get X to the
N or more familiarly what the derivative
of any member in this family is X to the
N provided that n is not equal to minus
1 now again this may look a little bit
abstract to you so to avoid this problem
let's just do a concrete illustration
let's pick a particular value of N and
work with this thing let's suppose we're
told to determine D inverse of X to the
seventh what does that mean what it
really means is let's find a function
whose derivative is X to the seventh and
why do I say let's find a function
because once I find a function all I
have to do is tack on arbitrary
constants and the family that I get that
way is the unique family of functions
which have this particular derivative so
I play the detective game I know from
differential calculus that if I
differentiate X to the 8th power I wind
up with the exponent seven at least in
other words the derivative of X to the
eighth power D of X to the eighth is
eight X to the seventh well what answer
did I want to get I wanted to get X to
the seventh not eight X to the seventh
so I fudge this thing a little bit
I say evidently what I should have done
was to have started with 1/8 as much in
other words multiplying equals by equals
I multiply both sides of this equation
by 1/8 and I wind up with 1/8 DX to the
8th equals x to the seventh and now
comes a very crucial step and let me
write that down because I think it's
something that we should pay very close
attention to and that is that the
derivative has the property that if you
want to differentiate a constant times a
function you can take the constant out
and differentiate just the function this
is a very crucial point because you see
and by the way notice that in general
not all functions have this property
enjoy mean for example if if you're
squaring something if you double the
number that's being
the output is four times as much because
twice something squared is four times as
much in other words in general you do
not say that if you double the input
you're going to double the output not
every function has that property but the
function called D the derivative does
have this particular property and you
see with that in mind I can bring this
one-eighth inside this is the key step
that that 1/8 times the derivative of X
to the eighth is a derivative of 1/8 X
to the eighth that's this key step over
here and now you see putting all this
together I find what that the derivative
of 1/8 X to the eighth is X to the
seventh and therefore since I've found
one function whose derivative is X to
the seventh I have in a sense found them
all namely 1/8 X to the eighth plus C in
other words that's what I call the
equivalent class of 1/8 X to the eighth
all the functions that differ from 1/8 X
to the 8th by a constant and again to
emphasize this very important point let
me again mention beware of non constant
factors let me give you a for instance
let's suppose I take almost the same
problem and it almost is a big almost
let's suppose I say let me find all
functions whose derivative say is x
squared plus 1 to the 7th power
in other words still something to the
seventh power so I do something like
well since whenever I differentiate I
reduce the exponent by one to wind up
with a seventh power maybe I should have
started with an eighth power so I say
okay that's what I'll do I'll start with
an eighth power so I say ok what is the
derivative of x squared plus 1 to the
eighth power now notice I know how to
differentiate hopefully and again let me
make this point very strongly there is
no sense studying inverse functions if
we don't know the original function
itself because the whole purpose of the
inverse function or the whole strategy
behind it is to reduce it to the
original function namely to switch the
emphasis so at any rate I differentiate
X square plus 1 to the 8th power I get 8
x squared plus 1 to the 7th
but now by the same rule I must remember
that this part was only the derivative
with respect to x squared plus one the
correction factor is what the derivative
of what's inside with respect to X
that's 2x and so I wind up with that if
i differentiate x squared plus 1 to the
8th
I get 16x times x squared plus 1 to the
7th now how much did I want to get I
wanted to get just x squared plus 1 to
the 7th that put me off by a factor of
16x now I say okay I'll fix that up
namely I'll divide both sides by 16x
assuming of course that X is not 0 and
this by the way is perfectly valid I can
now go from here to here and say look at
1 over 16 x times the derivative of x
squared plus 1 to the 8th with respect
to X is x squared plus 1 to the 7th
however notice that I cannot take this
factor and bring it inside here and
again as I so often have said also of
course I can bring it inside here I just
did what I mean is I don't get the right
answer and what's the best proof I don't
get the right answer very very simple
take this function differentiate it and
see if you get x squared plus 1 to the
7th you won't unless you differentiate
incorrectly don't be like the person who
just differentiates brings the 8 down
replaces this by one less multiplies by
a derivative of what's inside and
cancels everything out
notice that the expression inside the
brackets that I've just circled is a
quotient and the derivative of a
quotient is obtained in a very special
way to the denominator times the
derivative of the numerator minus the
numerator times the derivative of the
denominator over the square of the
denominator and all I'm saying is you
won't get x squared plus 1 to the 7th
power if you do that again notice that
you do not have to know the right answer
in order to see what answer is wrong
okay so this would be a wrong answer by
the way this would also be a wrong
answer because we've already seen that
the derivative of 1/8 x squared plus 1
to the 8th power is what you
the eight down which kills off the 1/8
you replace this to a power one less
which gives you x squared plus 1 to the
7th
but the correction factor here is you
must also multiply by the derivative of
what's inside respect to X and that's 2x
in other words you do not get x squared
plus 1 to the 7th what you do get is
what x squared plus 1 to the 7th times
2x and the question that may now come up
is how come this worked when you were
raising X to the 8th power but it didn't
work when you were raising x squared
plus 1 to the 8th power again as always
in these cases the answer is immediately
available in terms of derivatives we can
talk in fact about the inverse chain
rule that when we really talked about D
remember we mention this at the very
beginning of the lecture that the
variable inside the parentheses was the
one with respect to which you were
differentiating in other words what we
saw was that if you wanted to get
something to the seventh power what you
have to differentiate was 1/8 that same
something to the 8th power if you were
differentiating with respect to that
same variable in other words what would
have been x squared plus 1 to the 7th
would have been what if you were
differentiating not with respect to X
but with respect to x squared plus 1 see
what we really wanted when we wrote this
down was the derivative with respect to
X and even though this notation may look
a little bit strange to you observe that
once you get used to the notation this
is just another way of talking about the
chain rule namely to find the derivative
of this with respect to X you first take
the derivative with respect to x squared
plus 1
and then multiply that by the derivative
of x squared plus 1 with respect to X
and if we do that you see we get the
answer that we've talked about before in
other words what we could say is that
the function that you have to
differentiate to get x squared
plus 1 to the 7th times 2x is 1/8 x
squared plus 1 to the 8th plus a
constant and how do I know that
well the way I know that is simply what
in terms of inverse functions I started
with 1/8 x squared plus 1 to the 8th
differentiated it and found that I got x
squared plus 1 to the 7th times 2x and
so this became the recipe and again a
rather interesting aside if you look at
this and look at this
it would appear at first glance that the
top one should be ADA more difficult
problem than the bottom one the reason
being that the input seems more simple
in the bottom one yet the interesting
point is that the 2x which seems to make
this thing more complicated is precisely
the fact that you need by the chain rule
to make this thing work because when you
differentiate x squared plus 1 to the
8th power you're going to get a factor
of 2 X by the chain rule now again the
main aim of the lectures is not to take
the place of the computational drill
supplied in our exercises and in the
text but to give you sort of an insight
and there'll be plenty of drill on the
mechanics of this in our exercises on
this section let me just at least
continue on with the concept of our
recipes for example here's another one
and this one says what that if you run
the sum of two functions through the D
inverse machine the output is the same
as if you sent the functions through
separately and then added them up ok
I'll talk about that more in more detail
later
again all I want you to see is that this
is the analogous result of again a
beautiful property of the derivative and
that is that the derivative of a sum is
the sum of the derivatives and how does
that work over here again a very
interesting property throughout advanced
calculus linear algebra maleic these
properties are very very special and
we'll have occasion as the course goes
on to talk about them more for the time
being rather than have you get lost in
the maze of details let me work a
specific illustration let's suppose I
would like to find the family of
functions whose derivative is X to the
fifth plus X cubed ok
now what I'm saying is this by my
previous result I certainly know how to
find the function whose derivative is X
to the fifth namely 1/6 X to the sixth I
also know how to find the function whose
derivative is X cubed namely 1/4 X to
the fourth putting these two steps
together
and saying equals added to equals our
equal I can conclude that D of 1/6 X to
the sixth plus D of 1/4 X to the fourth
is X to the fifth plus X cubed now the
key step is that since the derivative of
a sum is the sum of the derivatives I
can say that the sum of these two
derivatives is the derivative of the sum
of the two functions namely that this is
what D of 1/6 X to the sixth plus 1/4 X
to the fourth a very important power and
property of the derivative therefore
have I found one function whose
derivative is X to the fifth plus X
cubed the answer is yes 1/6 X to the
sixth plus 1/4 X to the fourth therefore
what is the family of all functions
whose derivative is X 50 X cubed and
again as before the answer is take your
one solution that you found tack on an
arbitrary constant and I suppose
technically speaking I should put the
braces in here to indicate that my
solution is an infinite set all
belonging to one family called an
equivalent set of functions because they
have the same derivative well let's
continue on and do a little bit more
harder stuff remember we talked about
implicit differentiation well is there
an analogue to implicit D inverses you
see notice that in every problem so far
when I wrote D inverse I was essentially
telling you explicitly what came out of
the D machine now suppose I twist the
emphasis a little bit suppose I tell you
look at I run a certain function through
the D machine that was I form its
derivative what the output is is the
square of the reciprocal of the function
in other words if G of X comes in 1 over
G of x squared comes out and now the
question is what is the function G of X
and again notice that if we don't know
what the right G of X is you can
certainly test the given G of X to see
whether it's right or not namely what
could you do you differentiate G of X
see what you get and if what you get
isn't 1 over this one over the
square of G of X you've got the wrong
answer but the question that comes up is
given this type of a problem how do we
handle it C in other words how do we
have where does the inverse idea come in
here the implicit relationship that G of
X is determined by this particular
property and again notice how we use
properties of derivatives we're given
that G prime of X is a synonym identity
for 1 over G squared of X we can cross
multiply and we get G squared of x times
G prime of X is identically 1 now if you
clever about this and remember notice
this very very importantly for example
ordinary division is the inverse of
ordinary multiplication notice that to
be really cute in division you have to
be pretty cute in multiplication since
all you're doing is changing the
emphasis notice that to handle hard
problems in anti-derivatives you have to
be able to handle tough derivative
problems what I'm driving at is you look
at something like this and begin to
wonder do you know a function whose
derivative is this see the idea is if
you're familiar with you with your chain
rule what is the derivative of G cubed
of X to differentiate G cubed what do
you do you bring the 3 down to a power
one less times the derivative of G of X
with respect to X that your chain rule
that's G prime of X in other words if
you're clever enough to see this what
you say here is ok now I'll multiply
both sides by 3 see the left hand side
is just the derivative of G cubed of X
the right hand side is the derivative of
3x therefore whatever G of X is its cube
has the same derivative with respect to
X as 3x and we've already learned that
if two functions have identical
derivatives they differ by at most a
constant consequently G cubed of X must
equal 3 of 3x plus some constant in
other words
G of X is the cube root of 3x plus C now
time is running short in terms of other
things I want to teach you in today's
lesson let me leave this then just for
you to check simply differentiate the
cube root of 3x plus C and make sure
that when you get that to do that
derivative it does turn out to be 1 over
G of x squared as I say it's a
straightforward demonstration I leave
the details to you but the point that's
really important is that whenever you do
get an answer the hard part is to get
the answer whenever you do get the
answer you can check by means of just
taking a derivative now with all of this
talk about D inverse in mind let me now
go back to the more traditional notation
the notation that you'll find in most
textbooks the notation that as I say if
you've had calculus before most likely
you're more familiar with and that is
the following that where we write D
inverse of f of X the average textbook
writes a symbol like this it's called
the integral of f of X I will have later
lectures to bemoan this choice of
notation from a different point of view
but for the time being all we're saying
is instead of writing D inverse again
what's in the name just use this
particular notation that when you see
this particular thing perhaps read this
as what that this particular symbol is a
code to tell you to find all functions
whose derivative is f of X and by the
way to summarize the results that we've
obtained so far let me just rewrite some
of these basic results in terms of the
more traditional notation as when you
write this this is called the indefinite
integral and what we're saying is the
indefinite integral of x to the n DX is
X to the n plus 1 over n plus 1
plus a constant when n is not equal to
minus 1 the integral of a sum is the sum
of the integrals and the integral of a
constant times a function is a constant
time's the integral all this says is
what that you can this is a consequence
of the fact that the derivative of a sum
is the sum of the derivatives this is a
consequent of the fact that the
derivative of a constant times the
function is the constant times the
derivative of the function again all
this is same thing we were talking about
before only with the D inverse notation
replaced by the more common indefinite
integral now we come to one more problem
which will finish us up for the day once
we get through talking about it and
that's this if all this means is find
the functions whose derivative is f of X
right right this notation here why
couldn't we have just written for
example the so called integral sign
where little X underneath you see we've
talked about misleading notations before
you see in terms of our differential
notation when you see f of X DX you have
every right to think of a differential
now in all fairness the chances are that
this notation would not have been
invented if there weren't some
connection between derivatives and
differentials so let me mention this
point going back as if we were starting
the lecture all over again
could I have invented a different
machine which I'll call the script D
machine in other words I don't want to
call it the same D machine as before
because now it's going to have a
different set of outputs you see now the
input will still be differentiable
functions but the output instead of
being the derivative of the function
will be the differential of the function
for example before we said what if x
squared goes in the output would be 2x
with the scripting machine the output
would be 2x DX now even though these
machines are different because one
machine gives you a differential as an
output and the other gives you a
derivative as an output notice that they
are equivalent namely knowing the
differential we can pin down the
function the same as when we knew the
derivative now the question that comes
why should we use this particular type
of notation and to use the examples that
are most prevalent in the text and also
in our notes let me give you the same
problem that we've done before but now
from a different point of view suppose
we're still given the problem G prime of
x equals 1 over G of x squared we say ok
let y equal G of X when we do that this
problem now translates into what dy/dx
equals 1 over Y squared now if we allow
ourselves to use the differential
notation which we justified in previous
lectures this says what cross
multiplying y squared dy equals DX
notice by the way that Y is implicitly a
differentiable function of X so what
we're saying over here is look at here
are two functions which have the same
differential therefore if we integrate
them they differ by a constant well to
mimic what we're doing before let's just
say let's say this I think I have a
little bit twisted here if Y squared dy
equals DX 3y squared dy equals 3 DX if
the differentials are equal then the
function is different but Y cubed is the
function whose differential is 3 y
squared dy 3x is the function whose
differential is 3 DX and we wind up with
y cubed equals 3x plus C or y equals the
cube root of 3x plus C by the way let me
just pull this board down so that we can
make a little bit of a comparison here
you see notice that in using this
differential notation which allowed us
to use some nice algebraic devices and
didn't seem quite as difficult for us to
recognize certain things I hope you
notice that there seems to be a
correspondence between the steps that we
had here and the steps that took place
over here in other words having done it
the so-called rigorous way notice
that differentials give us a very nice
intuitively simpler technique for
solving certain types of problems when
we have implicit relationships between y
and X and so to just to illustrate this
in terms of one more problem let's take
one that's fairly geometric let's
suppose we were given the following
problem dy DX is minus x over Y and we
know that when x equals 3 y equals 4
using the language of differentials what
we would do over here is we would cross
multiply whatever you want to do it we
recognize that to get to why you must
differentiate y squared this is a step
you don't really need I don't care how
you want to do this all I'm saying is
that from this step I can get to here
recognizing that Y squared has to Y dy
as its differential and that minus x
squared has minus 2x DX as its
differential I know that Y squared is
equal to minus x squared plus a constant
I transpose I get that x squared plus y
squared is a constant knowing that when
x equals 3 y equals 4 I can determine
that the constant must be 25 when x
equals 3 and Y is 4 but since it's a
constant if it's 25 when x equals 3 and
y equals 4 it's 25 everyplace and again
if you want a geometric interpretation
of this the circle centered at the
origin with radius equal to 5 is the
only curve in the whole world whose
derivative at any given point is the
negative of the x coordinate over the y
coordinate and passes through the point
3 comma 4 and if you want to see that
geometrically let me just take a second
here you see notice that any point on
the circle X comma Y notice that the
tangent line to the curve which has
slope dy DX is what perpendicular to the
radius again the radius has slope Y over
X
and to be perpendicular if two lines are
perpendicular their slopes are negative
reciprocals this is this particular
problem problem and now all I wanted to
show you is that if you're nervous about
differentials and you don't like to use
them notice that the same problem could
have been stated without differentials
namely we are thinking of a function
which we'll call G of X such that the
derivative of G of X is minus x over G
of X in other words if the input of the
D machine is G the output is minus x
over G and we also know that when x
equals 3 the output is 4 so G of 3
equals 4 and without going through the
great details here let's just notice
that we could cross multiply the same as
before we could multiply both sides by 2
the same as before we could recognize
that the left-hand side was the
derivative of G of x squared that the
right-hand side is the derivative of
minus x squared therefore since they
have the same identical derivatives they
must differ by a constant okay
we crossed multiple we actually have
plus or minus here but notice the fact
that when the input is 3 the output is 4
means that we're on the positive branch
of the curve etc I say etc not because
these points aren't important but
because every point that comes up now
has already been discussed under the
heading of differential calculus in
other words that the inverse of
differentiation can be handled very very
neatly just by knowing differentiation
with a switch in emphasis why do we want
to know this particular topic well
because in many cases to look at it
geometrically in the past we were given
the funk the curve we want to find out
what a slope was in many physical
applications we are in a sense told what
the slope is and have to figure out what
the curve is hence the motivation well
at any rate there will be more about
this in the text and in our exercises so
until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate